j'espère que vous êtes bien attachés aux
sièges car aujourd'hui on va parler du
théorème le plus fou de tout les
mathématiques
on va parler du théorème d'incomplétude
de gödel ou plutôt on va parler des deux
théorème d'incomplétude de gödel le
premier affirme que l'arithmétique de p
and o ou toute extension de
l'arithmétique de p and o est forcément
incomplète
autrement dit et de façon grossière en
mathématiques il y aura toujours des
théorèmes vrai qu'ils n'ont pas de
preuves et si vous trouvez çà bizare
c'est normal on va expliquer tout ça le
second théorème lui affirme qu'il est
impossible de prouver la cohérence de
l'arithmétique de p and o et de ces
généralisations
en gros on ne pourra jamais être certain
que les mathématiques sont juste
qu'elles sont corrects et encore mois
qu'elles sont vraies mais avant d'en
arriver là
faisons un petit détour historique sa
grande conférence du tournant du siècle
en août 1900 david hilbert l'un des plus
grands mathématiciens du moment
affirmait qu'il était temps d'ériger les
mathématiques sur des fondations
inébranlable d un an plus tard la re30
sol détruisit les nombreuses premières
briques placé par frigo et kantor avec
un paradoxe dont on a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 16 au sol en compagnie
d'alfred nord whiteread passa ensuite
des décennies à tout reconstruire
aidé par d'autres grands logicien comme
ernst réservé l'eau ou encore abraham
uncle malgré de nombreux hauts et bas en
1930 il bertu suffisamment confiance en
les progrès de la logique au point de
déclarer à la radio l'une des citations
les plus tragiquement fausse de
l'histoire des mathématiques
hilbert affirma ne faut pas croire ceux
qui aujourd'hui à partir de fondements
philosophiques et avec un ton désinvolte
prophétise l'effondrement de la culture
et accepte league n'aura bib mousse
savoir le fait de me passer
or pour nous il n'y a pas dit que nora
bib mousse par opposition à ces icônes
aura blues ridicule notre slogan se doit
d'être et un bus une vie bien werden
bilson sauf que sauf que non le premier
théorème d'incomplétude prouve justement
qu'il restera toujours dans les
mathématiques peu importe les axiomes
que le considère des vérités sur les
nombres les courbes ou encore les
ensembles que nos outils mathématiques
ne pourront jamais découvrir
pire encore le second théorème
d'incomplétude affirme que l'on ne
pourra jamais savoir si ce que l'on a
découvert avec nos outils mathématiques
vraiment vrai et là j'espère que vous
comprenez pourquoi les torts m
d'incomplétude de gödel sont bien les
théorèmes les plus fous de tout les
mathématiques et pourquoi lorsqu'il les
entendit john von neumann affirma c'est
fini bref avec cette introduction assez
longue
j'espère que je vous ai donné vraiment
envie de vouloir comprendre cet om
d'incomplétude de gueule et ça tombe
bien puisque on va maintenant voir la
preuve en tout cas on va essayer de voir
quelques idées de la preuve du premier
théorème d'incomplétude de gödel alors
je préfère vous prévenir ça a piqué un
ça va piquer mais je ne peux pas ne pas
vous parler de quelques idées de la
preuve de ce théorème fou avant d'aller
plus loin surtout si vous n'avez jamais
entendu parler du théorème de gödel je
vous conseille très fortement d'aller
voir l'excellente vidéo de sciences
étonnante à ce sujet mais aussi les
vidéos qui précède cet épisode dans ma
série sur l'infini en particulier les
épisodes 13 14 15 16 et 17
oui je sais ça fait beaucoup mais je
vous le promets ça vaut vraiment le coup
assez traîné allons-y pour commencer il
faut rappelle que les théories
mathématiques doivent être écrites dans
un langage précis fait d'un nombre
infini de simple logique et d'un nombre
dénombrable de variables qui représente
les objets de la théorie mathématique
la première étape de la preuve de gödel
consiste à encoder les formules de la
théorie mathématique par des entier pour
ce faire gödel associe à tout symbole et
à tout variable un entier le nombre
associé à une formule avec un symbole
est obtenu en multipliant les haines
premiers nombres premiers avec des
exposants qui correspondent aux symboles
encoder les détails de l'encodage
importe peu en fait ils sont assez
technique même vachement technique parce
que gödel devait s'assurer qu'ils
pouvaient se faire cet encodage à l'aide
du langage de l'arithmétique de p and o
lui même et comme on l'a vu dans un
épisode précédent
ce langage est quand même vachement
illimitée nous joueurs on a tendance à
utiliser tout l'arsenal de
l'informatique pour effectuer de telles
encodage si bien que ça vous choque
peut-être pas de savoir que toutes les
données du web les images instagram les
vidéos youtube ou vos posts twitter ou
facebook sont tous encoder par tes
nombre des très grand nombre
à l'instar des codes de gödel la vidéo
youtube que vous êtes en train de
regarder correspond à un nombre super
méga lé géant qui correspond à un nombre
de l'ordre de 10 puissance 10 puissance
10 nous plus grand que beaucoup beaucoup
plus grand que le nombre de particules
dans l'univers et ce nombre super méga
géant contient toutes les informations
de toutes les couleurs de tous les
pixels et tous les timbres de voix que
j'utilise dans cette vidéo c'est ce
qu'on entend d'ailleurs par information
digitale c'est dire que toutes les
informations peuvent être encodé par des
nombres mais bref
revenons-en à la gueule du dell avait
réussi en connaît toutes les formules
mathématiques par des nombres mais aussi
toutes les preuves des théorèmes
mathématiques et même toutes les
tentatives de preuves des théories
mathématiques tout ça c'est super joli
mais ce n'est pas encore vraiment
incroyable le tour de force monstrueux
de gödel fut de montrer qu'une tentative
de démonstration des mots d'un théorème
théorème
pouvait se réécrire dans le langage de
l'arithmétique de p and o comme étant
une formule pour appeler prouve qu'il y
les codes numériques des mots qui et
l'encodage de la démonstration et
théorème qui et l'encodage numérique du
théorème et ça c'est très très très fort
cette formule logique prouve contient
toutes les règles de la logique mais
aussi tous les axiomes de la théorie
mathématique que l'on est en train de
considérer ce tour de force monstrueux
gaudeul il aussi beaucoup trop compliqué
beaucoup trop long à expliquer pour que
vous en tendant une vidéo mais j'ai bien
envie de vous donner une idée de la
difficulté technique en jeu et de
quelques moyens de la résoudre pour cela
plutôt que d'essayer de déterminer la
formule logique qui correspond à la
notion de prouver je vous propose
d'essayer d'écrire dans le langage de
l'arithmétique de p and o l'équation 10
puissance n est égal à x et souvenez
vous de l'épisode 13 devrait pas le
droit d'utiliser cet exposant et vous
n'avez pas le droit d'utiliser un
chapeau ou quoi que ce soit tout ce dont
vous avez le droit comme symbole ce sont
les symboles de la logique le zéro le
plus le foie et le symbole égale
particulier pas de points de suspension
ça veut rien dire dans le langage de la
musique de piano
si vous êtes chauds et n'hésitez pas à
mettre pause maintenant mais je préfère
vous prévenir
c'est un exercice super difficile
l'astuce pour écrire dispute en scène
est égal à x dans le langage de paix à
nos c'est donc au dé toutes les étapes
intermédiaires de calcul un dix cents
-jusqu'à discussions saines à
l'intérieur d'un très grand nombre elle
pour récupérer les différentes étapes de
calcul on peut prendre des espèces de
projection de l que l'on peut calculer à
l'aide des outils classiques de
l'arithmétique typiquement pour
récupérer la yam étape du calcul on peut
prendre le reste de l modulo a plus une
fois m ou à cm sont des espèces de
paramètres de la projection en question
du coup toutes les étapes de calcul sont
encodées par le triplet l aeem n'aura
alors discussion saine est égal à x6
toutes les étapes du calculs sont justes
et si la énième étape du calcul donne
bien le résultat
x si je combine tout ça ça me donne la
formule équivalente à 10 puissance n est
égal à x écrite dans le langage de
l'arithmétique p and o décrite par il
existe elle il existe à et il existe m
tel que pour tous si si il y est entre 0
et n - 1 alors l'aï plus 1e étape de
calcul est 10 fois lahiya méthode de
calcul tels que la première étape de
calcul est égal à 1 est telle que la
énième étape de calcul est égal à x
alors je suis pas allé au bout du
raisonnement je compte sur vous pour le
compléter en particulier maintenant il
reste à écrire mode
np dans le langage de l'arithmétique de
p and o bref avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail encore et en
s'inspirant de ce petit exemple il est
possible de trouver une formule logique
qui correspond à des mots prouve
théorème ou des mots et or m6 on
dénombre et où cette formule-là est vrai
si et seulement si lorsque je décode le
mode emo et je décode le mot théorème
j'obtiens alors une vraie démonstration
mathématique est un vrai théorème
mathématique dans le langage
arithmétique de pernod et à ce moment là
la formule des mots prouve théorème sera
vrai si et seulement si la démonstration
décoder prouvent en effet le théorème
décoder c'est incroyable la validité
d'une démonstration mathématique peut
s'écrire dans le langage même de la
théorie mathématique en question et je
vous rappelle au passage que les axiomes
de la théorie mathématique en question
interviennent dans la construction
de la formule logique associés à la
formule proof et c'est pas étonnant
puisque la validité d'une preuve
mathématique dépend des actions on a
fait la moitié du chemin
mais reste encore un énorme coup de
génie de gödel à comprendre
pour y arriver il faut bien comprendre
que les formules logique peuvent avoir
des variables par exemple dans la
formule des mots prouve théorème on a
deux variables qui sont des mots et
théorème qui je vous le rappelle sont en
fait des nombres on peut considérer en
particulier des formules qui ont une
seule variable et en particulier on peut
encoder ce de telles formules donc par
exemple si x est un nombre qui
correspond à une formule des codes x qui
contient une variable alors à ce moment
là je peux appliquer des codes x ax qui
correspond alors une formule close c'est
à dire une formule qui ne dépend plus
d'un paramètre et en particulier de
telles formules sont forcément vraies ou
fausses et ensuite un coup de génie de
godorf d'introduire un laine qui dit
qu'une certaine formule n'a pas de
preuve
la formule en question s'obtient en
appliquant le décodage d'une variable x
à la variable x trop m'en dit len 2x va
être la formule qui dit que pour tous
nombre qui correspond à une
démonstration des mots il est faux de
dire que des mots prouve ce que
j'obtiens lorsque je décode x et que je
l'appliqué à x en fait bien gaffe à cela
mais il est super subtil et devrait
avoir plein de noeuds au cerveau qui
vont vous apparaître signalé un peu
doucement
la plupart du temps lorsque je prends un
nombre entier hic c'est que je le décode
des codes x va être une formule logique
mais qui peut avoir pas mal de variables
012 ou plus
du coup la formule logique des codes x
ne correspondra pas forcément à ce
schéma qui est donnée par le laine
appliqué à x ça ça importe peu puisque
ce qui va nous intéresser en fait c'est
lorsqu'on olympique le lève à une
certaine variable qui correspond bel et
bien à une formule qui dépend d'une
variable donc les laids mais en fait
particulièrement intéressant lorsque je
lui donne un nombre x qui lorsque je le
décode donne une formule qui dépendent
d'une variable et lorsque l'on à un
nombre x qui lorsque mon dos des codes
donne bien une formule à une variable le
lem appliqué à x va se poser la question
de l'existence d'une preuve de l'ours
que j'applique la formule associé à x a
son propre code x hockey du coup le lait
m'appliquer à x va nous dire quelque
chose sur les formules qui ont une
variable mais bien sûr le lempicka x
n'est pas vrai en tant que tel ça dépend
de la valeur de x pour en faire un vrai
théorème il faut trouver une valeur
intéressante de x a donné à solesmes et
je vous rappelle que cette valeur
pertinente de x doit forcément
correspondant une formule logique à une
variable ce que vous avez une idée de la
formule logique a donné au lait
m'appliquer à x oui c'est ça on va
appliquer le lem 2x à x est égal au liem
lui même et ça
donne le théorème de la mort qui tue le
théorème de la mort qui tue de gödel
c'est ce que j'obtiens lorsque je donne
oleme de la mort qui tue de gödel le
code du lem de la mort qui tue de gödel
autrement dit le théorème de la mort qui
tue de gödel et le théorème qui est
égale oleme appliquée aux codes du lem
vous voyez pourquoi c'est fou calculons
le théorème le théorème maintenant on
nous dit que pour toute tentative de
démonstration des mots il est faux de
dire que des mots prouve le code de
leyme appliquée aux codes de leyme
vous le voyez venir la formule exacte du
théorème apparaît dans le théorème en
fait si on réécrit cela on voit que le
théorème dit que pour toute tentative de
démonstration des mots il est faux de
dire que des mots prouve le théorème
vous comprenez ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que le théorème affirme que le
théorêt n'a pas de preuve
donc si le théorème et fo se voudra dire
qu'il a une preuve et du coup il serait
vrai du coup on sait que le théorème est
vrai mais aussi qui n'existe pas de
preuve à 7 et oren c'est ainsi que de la
démontrer qu'il existe au moins un
théorème qui est vrai mais n'a pas de
prof l'aller enfin à parler de 4
paradoxe de la logique mathématique et
vous allez poser notamment un défilé le
défilé était le suivant la deux portes
devant nous une mène au paradis des
autres à l'enfer et on a 1 devant nous
un ange qui pourrait être en fait un
démon donc l'ange dit toujours la vérité
le démon bon tout le temps et vous
n'avez le droit qu'à une seule question
quelles questions poser pour savoir
quelle porte mène au paradis car l'enfer
vous avez été très nombreux à donner des
bonnes réponses donc vraiment
félicitations ça me fait super plaisir
de voir tous vos messages je sais pas
qu'est la fraction d'entre vous qui
connaissait déjà la réponse à cette
énigme
j'espère qu'elle était très faible
quelque chose à dire que beaucoup de
vous d'entre vous ont juste découvert la
solution est quelqu'un félicitations
alors il y avait plusieurs réponses
possibles et dans les commentaires
plusieurs réponses différentes l'une de
ses réponses et résumé par frédéric
boulet qui dit qu'ils proposent à la
question suivante avec moi quel est la
porte qui mène chez toi en effet l'enjeu
va indiquer du coup la porte qui mène au
paradis et le démon lui devrait montrer
la porte qui mène à l'enfer
sauf qu'il manque du coup il va montrer
le paradis à suivre direction indiquée
par l'enjeu sage d explicitation à ceux
qui ont trouvé ça bon ça suppose quand
même que l'enjeu vient du paradis et le
démon vient de l'enfer ce qui est
communément admis dans la culture
populaire mais moi j'en ça c'est très
possible que les démons vivent au
paradis et que les anges vivent en enfer
peut-être je sais pas du coup on
pourrait vouloir demander à ce que la
réponse ne fait pas intervenir l'origine
de la personne avec qui on pose la
question peut supposer que c'est juste
quelqu'un dont on sait juste qu'ils me
ment tout le temps ou qu'il ait tout en
la vérité et non ça c'est rien sur son
passé quelques à la proposition
excellente de frédéric boulet mais aussi
de d'autres à ce moment-là ce genre de
réponse ne marche plus on a les bonnes
réponses de professeurs culture
précieuses et de stu
[Musique]
excusez moi pour la prononciation qui
consiste à demander à l'ange s'acheter
mon situé telle inverse de ce que tu
étais si c'est demandé quelle porte mène
au paradis qu'elle portman statut en
effet si on parlait un lange et ben
lange directeur la vérité du coup pour
répondre à la question il doit se faire
passer pour le démon qui lui indiquerait
la porte de l'enfer et comme l'ange doit
dire la vérité du coup il indiquerait la
porte de l'enfer al'inverse aussi
question était posée aux démons lors des
mondes devra imaginer ce que dirait
blanche qui lui indiquera la porte du
paradis et comme le des moments ils
devraient montrer
du coup de l'autre porte à l'enfer dans
les deux cas la porte qui a été indiqué
par l'injuste acheté mon et celles de
l'enfer
du coup il faudra prendre l'autre porte
qui mène au paradis ça c'est un tout
petit peu alambiqué et depuis en fait il
y avait une meilleure réponse qui ma
réponse préféré qui a été proposée
notamment par antoine delaigue même si
en fait encore une fois il ya pas mal
d'autres parmi vous qui l'ont trouvé
désolé de pas repris de temps de lister
tous ceux qui ont donné les bonnes
réponses du cas la bonne réponse en
question qui est ma préférée c'est
subjectif mais c'est ce que je préfère
c'est de poser à l'enjeu sage démons la
question suivante si je te demandais
quelle porte mène au paradis qu'elle
porte me montrerai tue c'est assez
subtil en fait c'est pour ça que j'aime
bien ça donc si la personne est l'ange
du coup elle est juste indiqué le
paradis mais si la personne est en fait
le démon du coup il doit se placer dans
le cas où on lui demande quelle porte
mène au paradis
et dans ce cas imaginaire il montrera du
coup l'enfer mais du coup comme on lui a
demandé d'imaginer ce cas est de donner
la réponse qui donnerait dans ce cas
imaginaire il m'en tirais sur ce qu'il
aurait déjà menti et du congo est une
négation de la négation et en
particulier et répondre l inverse de ce
qu'ils auraient répondu comme leur a
répondu l'enfer du coup il va montrer le
paradis et du coup dans les deux cas
le démon ça change montrera la porte du
qui mène au paradis est sûre il suffira
de suivre cette porte là donc vraiment
je pense que je trouve super aller
grande partie que vous voyez que
l'astuce à chaque fois consiste à faire
parler non joue le slash le démon de
lui-même peu c'est vraiment aussi
l'astuce qui est au coeur du paradoxe de
russell est au coeur du théorème
d'incomplétude de l'autre on vient de
parler je reviens aussi sur la question
de fond est boueux du prix du porc
désolé prononciation qui nous demandent
en quoi le fait de rajouter une pomme
qui fait objection entraîné air implique
un paradoxe fait que c'est du coup ce
n'est pas une question de taille en fait
c'est pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment
lié ce que j'essaie vraiment de dire ce
que j'ai essayé de dire plutôt dans la
vidéo précédente
c'est que la notion de taille conte avec
lequel on raisonne de façon visuelle en
mathématiques standard est en fait une
notion artificiel c'est un peu une
surinterprétation de la théorie
mathématique
si on regarde juste les symboles de la
logique et les symboles langage de paix
à nos hôpitaux de les élèves saison
comparé à dans l'épisode précédent
on voit que la notion de taille
n'apparaît pas et tout ce qu'il y a en
fait cessé notion d'ensemble puis on
aller un peu plus loin et parler de
fonction une fonction encore une fois là
ce serait d interprétation d'ensemble
au final tout ce qui compte c'est des
ensembles et et des relations entre les
ensembles ce sur quoi j'ai essayé
vraiment d'insister c'est que en fait
dans la théorie des ensembles même été
ensemble moderne comme d'hab c'est tout
n'est qu'une question de l'objet
mathématique et de relations entre ces
objets mathématiques
la notion de taille des ensembles est
quelque chose que l'on ajoute bien plus
tard et qui une façon d'interpréter
certains théorème que l'on a
qui dit pareil qui par exemple disent
que
le fait qu'un ensemble soit plus petit
qu'un autre est une relation d'ordre sur
l'ensemble des ensembles chose comme ça
soissons est utile parce que l'ensemble
est dantesque pas mais ce sont des
relations assez intuitive que l'on se
permet de construire parce qu'ils sont
consistants en haut avec les théorèmes
que l'on a déjà prouvé
sauf que lorsqu'on est confronté au
terme de ce collège les forces et de se
rendre compte que les notions de taille
qu'on a introduites pour mieux parler
des théorèmes qu'on a déjà prouvé son
d'une certaine manière assez
inconsistant avec ou pas tout à fait
adéquat pour vraiment comprendre la
théorie des ensembles et pour notamment
l'a interprété à la lumière du théorème
de laval m c'est pour ça que la notion
de taille je dirais pas qu'elles
n'existent pas il dit juste qu'elle
n'est pas pertinente
une fois que l'on réfléchit en termes de
l'ohvn hamas collègues et de ses notions
de modèles mathématiques et de cette
façon de parler des mathématiques en
dehors d'une théorie mathématique les
langages la théorie mathématique
tout ça c'est super bizarre et c'est un
niveau vraiment plus beaucoup au delà du
niveau master master logique
mathématique peut-être du coup ça vole
très haut c'est très compliqué à
expliquer c'est très difficile à
comprendre
je ne prétends pas du tout comprendre
tout cela je vous ai juste trop sortie
l'explication que m'avait sorti mon ami
logicien que j'ai trouvé assez
convaincante mais je conçois tout à fait
que ça n'a pas du tout été complètement
clair
enfin je vais revenir sur la question de
doctorat peyron qui nous demandent est
ce que la logique mathématique est
vraiment la vraie logique est ce qu'on
les logiciens pense que ces avoirs
logique voire faux césar peu russell
était logicien
philosophe ch mathématicien qu'il faille
y naviguer vraiment à l'inter c'est
comme tous et de toutes ces disciplines
et c'était le leader indiscutable au
tournant du siècle peu après le vent du
siècle du coup bon je pense compliqué
pas trop faux de dire que la logique
mathématique et qui a essayé
d'introduire org
russell était vraiment la logique n'est
de la même façon google était considéré
comme le plus grand logis siens sont de
tous les temps du coup je pense que les
logiciens sage philosophe s'accordent à
dire que la logique introduite par lieu
dole et russell sont des logiques
vraiment la vraie logique donc ça c'est
un peu un argument d'autorité slash de
sociologie des sciences
après si on veut essayer de comprendre
pourquoi est ce que ça sera vraiment la
vraie logique
je sentais vraiment à se demander
qu'est-ce que comment est ce que vous
définiriez la logique après on partirait
de choses qui sont vraies ou fausses
donc s'appelle l'élite héros des
formules unique qui sont vraies ou
fausses mais après on a les règles
logiques vrai est vrai se fait vrai
vraies et fausses à fait faux vrais faux
et faux c'est faux faux et vrai ça il
faut au pays commence à construire
toutes ces règles aux logiques vous vous
rendez compte ensuite que toutes ces
règles logiques ce a priori ne
s'intéresse qu'à un nombre fini de se
rappelle denis terreau sert de trucs
vrai ou faux de proposition et que c'est
assez limité si on en reste là pour
aller vraiment plus loin
faut passer à une infinité possible de
littéraux pour vraiment continuer à
explorer et surtout produire des
nouvelles formules logique qu'on n'a pas
envie encore anticiper et à ce moment là
on arrive tout de suite sur la logique
du premier orgue et on peut se demander
de quoi ça parlait bas si dd qu'on veut
parler d'une infinité de choses on à la
structure des nombres entiers naturels
qui apparaît du coup assez naturellement
du coup j'ai envie de dire enfin que la
logique mathématique c'est ce qui se
rapproche le plus de ce qu'on pourra
appeler la vraie logique mais bon
peut-être que je me trompe et s'il ya
des philosophes ou des logiciels parmi
vous qui sont pas d'accord dit l'émoi
dans les commentaires il reviendra sur
ça je serai passionnés savoir
ç'aurait les réponses alternatives à ce
genre de questions dernière chose que
j'aimerais rajouter à tout ça c'est que
parfois on parle pas mal de paradoxal
logique par exemple pardoxe de taizé qui
dit que si on a un bateau ton change
toutes les pièces offertes en mesure à
ce que ça reste le même bateau ça c'est
pas vraiment des problèmes de la logique
c'est plus d'épreuves de sémantique de
savoir qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'une
individualité qu'est ce qu'un objet tout
ça c'est déjà de plus des questions
d'interprétation de sens des mots de
l'interprétation que des idées vraiment
des trucs très logique de base savoir
qu'est ce qui est vrai et faux et du
coup c'est logique plus plus fou c'est
nous qui s'éloigne du coût de la logique
mathématique sont aussi moins de la
logique au sens premier du terme au sens
pur mais bon je suis conscient que c'est
un avis assez matin que j'ai du coup
peut-être que je me trompe complètement
si je me trompe si vous pensez que je me
trompe et commentaires sont faits pour
ça je serais heureux de les lire
elle espère que vous avez mais c'est
l'épisode la prochaine fois on va parler
de la théorie des ensembles mais pas
naïve on va parler de la théorie nfc et
en particulier ont essayé de répondre
enfin à la question mais qu'est ce qu'on
étudie vraiment en mathématiques ou en
tout cas en mathématiques standard
notamment on va parler de bourbaki et
tous allez savoir comment on construit
les nombres et structure mathématique à
partir d'une théorie des ensembles
uniquement si vous avez aimé cet épisode
tant celle là est le commentaire de
partage et pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer sur l'épisode merci aux
outils performants et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois alors faut
quand même dire un truc sauter rome il a
été beaucoup abusé et déformé pour lui
faire dire tout et n'importe quoi
on a donc réussi à construire une
contradiction donnant de notre unique
suppositions de départ qu'un tel
programme stop exister et donc nous
venons de démontrer qu'un tel programme
n'existe pas